foreign
next we have miles and Boise Idaho hey
miles welcome to the show
hey hello thank you so much for taking
my call absolutely how can we help
okay so I've uh you know recently I
started this into you guys thanks to a
brother of mine and uh my main goal is
to get out of debt obviously my
mentality was that's something that
shifted recently awesome but I find I
find myself in significant amount of
debt
um I'm wondering
uh total with everything I'm at a
hundred and eighteen thousand that
doesn't include my home yeah is that
does that include your home
it does not it is okay no in addition to
that would be 404 000 for my home okay
how much do you make a year
uh well I just started a business and so
I'm coming in on my second year and last
year we did a 152 000 gross
is that what you made or is that what
you took home
no
um I was what I made was closer eighty
thousand okay
what makes up the 118
uh so I have five credit cards
and I have five I have three auto loans
I have one uh loan on my equipment that
I use and then I have another uh another
loan on a building that I that I have in
my backyard like a shed kind of thing
okay
um so you're just kind of you're just
kind of normal
I'm just kind of normal just kind of a a
American normal got some credit cards
some
right a shed in the back
how much is your mentality my mentality
up to this point has been well it fits
into my monthly budget I can afford it
monthly right and so yeah yeah like I
said I've had to shift that mentality
and now I kind of feel like I'm drowning
and being that I'm two years into
business this was the first winter that
I came into or work slowed down
significantly and now I really feel
you're feeling it yeah how much is your
mortgage payment on that on that four
hundred and four thousand
twenty three hundred dollars okay well
that's not you know for an eighty
thousand dollar income that's not
um outrageous uh as ratios because we
want it to be about 25 of your income
um being towards your mortgage payment
um so Miles I mean honestly what I would
look at if I were you
um is I would list everything out and I
would say what can I sell today what can
I sell we have three vehicles we got we
got crap around our house that were
probably bought on these credit cards
that we don't need can my wife sell
stuff online uh we're taking TVs off so
like we are going crazy because here's
the deal miles you guys have just been
living what you feel in the moment and
you just kind of keep going and Trucking
and it's caught up with you and so now
you're at this point where you're
thinking holy crap what have we done
what are we doing and so you have to
have a level of an extreme change to
start to feel some traction so if again
if I were you I would be selling
everything possible liquidate as much as
you can to get some of the 118 dad I
mean how much is it on the cars total
all three cars how much of that is 118.
on the three cars I'm at forty thousand
okay with all three total
yes and then I have 25 000 on my
equipment that I run
um and do you need that for your
business
I do yes all right another thing if
you're running your business out of your
home checking account that's a whole
other issue man you need to separate
those expenses out you got to pay your
debt off but
man if you're running this stuff through
your home budget your create you're
going to create all kind of chaos for
you for your taxes for your business for
all of you yeah separating that's going
to be important so yeah miles I mean
honestly I would go scorched Earth
everything to attack this debt and
you're going to start to see the light
at the end of the tunnel especially if
you go extreme and you sell some if you
sell this stuff you work extra you guys
go all the way in it's going to be
amazing amazing what happens with the
progress